how did you get into film and how'd you
get so good at it I didn't finish high
school Jason I know we both did our
thing on Twitter of our first five jobs
yeah and I was like dishwasher and
you're like so be sure water
I put Porter instead of janitor because
that sounded fancier that's my
grandfather used to call a rest in peace
Porter no I died I you know it's like
you grew up in New York grew up in
southeastern Connecticut okay obviously
the the poor part yeah the shitty part
Connecticut's a fancy state anchor when
you go right outside New York City
getting this the Stanford's and the
Stanford's in the in the Greenwich these
beautiful they're expensive challenges
and then the other side of the state is
sort of a where I grew up was kind of a
lower middle class military industrial
town remember when Reagan left office
like all my friends parents lost their
jobs because we you know we used to
build submarines right there right yeah
I could ride my bike to the second
biggest submarine base in the in the
country it's right down the street from
where I lived what did your parents do
him curious my dad is he used when I
grew up was a used restaurant supply
salesman Wow
yeah and my mom playing um rake not
quite
I mean Ray Kroc was great at selling
milkshake milkshake machines uh
no my yeah my dad sell dishwashers and
forks and knives yeah my dad is a small
restaurants in Brooklyn yeah restaurant
business my mom didn't really work yeah
my mom my dad now know owns a coffee
shop really yeah how's your relationship
with your dad is he like blown away by
what you've accomplished
it must be mind-blowing for him it's
mind-blowing for my dad but he has a
hard time saying it yeah I you talked to
him about it yeah sort of I mean I think
it was exciting for us both because you
know my dad I'm like I remember vividly
I should probably word-for-word recite
it when I was 16 years old calling my
dad to tell him that my girlfriend was
pregnant and to give that some context I
you know I left home when I was 15 and
never went back and never took a penny
from my parents never you were a
freshman in high school sophomore
left home and never turn back and this
is pretty cell phone this is before like
they couldn't contact me there you were
legal age to work I wasn't allowed to go
to school because I didn't I didn't have
parental consent
Wow so if you can and I can now
empathize with him because I'm a parent
but if you put yourself in his shoes
like you've got this kid who's always in
trouble who then left home and you don't
know where he is or what he's up to or
what he's doing and I moved I left that
moved to Virginia my brothers in college
there and you don't hear from your Kelly
Dan call honey wasn't calling my parents
I was angry I ran away from home because
I was so angry and then you get a call
from your kid and you said he says hey
dad I'm having a baby Wow and I felt
like I was an adult at age 16 but you
know now in 16 year-olds are children
like I have a 21 year old son and I
think that he's just now really starting
to become his own person and become a
man and all those things his frontal
lobes have not fully developed yet he's
think it's 23 or 24 when your brain is
fully developed so you can make
decisions yeah but at the age of 16 your
kid so in any event for my dad to see
and then I was I was probably most
closest with my dad when I was in the
struggle like when I was I moved back to
Connecticut and I lived in a trailer
park not far from him and you know I had
to call my dad and ask him like how do I
get a rest how do I get a job in a
restaurant and he said well let me call
around cuz he sold all these rooms yeah
and that's how I got my job as a
dishwasher so my dad knew intimately
that like his at the time 17 year old
kid is trying to support his family off
of 8 bucks an hour washing dishes at
that kind of shitty restaurant that I
hoped my job is 12 hour shift typically
1012 hours egg for the 12 hour shift so
they're usually pretty cautious about
making sure never cross 40 hours they
didn't want to take time and a half yeah
I know I was getting 8 bucks an hour all
right what the waitstaff got for an hour
because they had tips right but I paid
them less than minimum wage I never got
tips I get the apron they narrow hands
at the end of the day or just like it
was like yeah like you were swimming for
10 hours I often talk about that because
I think that when people say like where
did you get your
where did I kind of find my own ambition
or my own passion and my career and
things like that I always say that if
you don't if you don't know what you
want to do in life spend as much time as
you can doing something you absolutely
[ __ ] hate oh yeah because spending
eight hours a day actually did two jobs
they wouldn't give me overtime so I got
another job in another restaurant so for
me it was spending eight to sixteen
hours a day scrubbing pots and like
every time I picked up that steel wool
and every time like just the smell and
would have to change my apron three
times a shift it was just constantly in
my brain like [ __ ] this is not where I
want to be this is not where on the body
yeah and any really that galvanizes your
resolve to what's that
what's the because there's like an
academic term when you go from having
little means having a lot of means we
change your station in life you become
affluent no no there's like that there's
a term for it it's yeah but you ain't
kind of high school so I don't know if
this I can't remember what the word is
but it's it's like when you go when you
transport from one place to another
mobility mobility like that that resolve
to for mobility yeah in my life was
really really set in concrete in while I
was scrubbing pots